all right one of the cable news clip I
want to play for you uh this is a
insurrectionist Justin Pearson who
appeared on MSNBC
um and I just want you to listen to what
he has to say
this is going to be the way it is you
and your generation and people like you
and Zoe Zephyr and Maxwell Frost you're
not afraid to break the China
we have to realize that we are in a
really important moment in the movement
uh not just in a moment and for our
entire generation which recognizes that
the opportunity that we have cannot be
wasted by going along with the status
quo as usual the status quo has propped
up white supremacy and patriarchy and
Injustice it has created a situation
where in a state like Tennessee we have
an increase in poverty we have some of
the lowest voter turnout we have a
situation where we have this epidemic of
gun violence and the Silence from
leaders in the Republican party in our
state house and we know that things can
be different and it can be better and so
in this moment I believe the moral
courage of all of our generation is
Awakening to our power and we were told
how important Civics was in voting and
participating in democracy and this is a
shame that in Tennessee and in Montana
we are saying that participation in
democracy seeking to be silent censured
or expelled because it is advocating for
a vision and a voice that needs to be
heard and it is a vision that says every
everybody matters that there is a
movement of people who are young and who
are fearless in the face of Injustice
and fearless in the face of Oppression
because we know that we are part of a
long story history of people who have
built movements that have been
multiracial that have been for the true
Spirit of democracy that have helped to
create the present conditions that we
have to be able to sit in the seats that
we have in order to elevate the issues
and the voices of our community and and
we're not going to stop and we're not
going to be turned around
you know uh there's a couple funny
things there one is that you could tell
he doesn't quite know how to speak like
a normal person right now because he has
this character this absurd uh cartoonish
character that he plays on TV when he's
up there pretending to be a civil rights
icon from the 1960s and doing that whole
routine but he hasn't quite figured out
and these that you know that's like the
big over the top
um moment that that he's he's that he
can do and I'm not gonna say that he
does it convincingly or does it well but
he can do that
um
but it's the subtle acting that he
hasn't quite figured out and this is
also I think this is true even of
Hollywood actors you know it's one thing
they have the big emotional moment is
one thing but to have to capture those
kind of subtler moments is that's a more
difficult acting and so when he's giving
these interviews where he's not in front
of a crowd with a bullhorn you know
doing his whole Martin Luther King Jr
stick
and he's just supposed to be talking
like a normal person he doesn't quite he
he sort of lapses into the character and
then he comes back out of it he doesn't
quite know how to talk like a normal
person everyone's talking about how chat
GPT and artificial intelligence are
going to change the world tech companies
are all investing heavily in AI for a
search but guess what they're also the
same big tech companies that determine
your search results only now they get to
cut out a whole new layer from the
information you get to see why should
they link to third-party websites in the
search results when they can let their
robot generate the perfect answer for
your question right away and that's why
I use expressvpn to add a layer of
protection between me and big Tech
expressvpn's app hides my unique IP
address on all of my devices this makes
it much harder much more difficult for
big Tech to identify who I am and match
my activity back to me I've been using
expressvpn for years all I have to do is
tap one button on my phone or computer
to turn it on and that's it it really is
that simple and easy expressvpn doesn't
just uh protect me from Big Tech it also
encrypts 100 of my online traffic
keeping me safe from hackers and prying
eyes
one expressvpn subscription covers up to
five devices at the same time so my
whole family can use it to stop letting
big Tech leech on your data freely visit
expressvpn.com Walsh right now to get
three extra months free that's exp
rssvpn.com Walsh to get protected with
vpns the VPN rated number one by CNET
Tech right radar and most importantly by
me expressvpn.com Welsh one thing about
men is that we hate going to the doctor
you have to make the appointment you
have to spend half your day sitting
around the waiting room often endure
uncomfortable conversations about your
body with another man that you hardly
know Rex MD understands that no one
likes to go to the doctor's office
that's why they've created a safe online
platform for men to discreetly consult
with the licensed Physicians and get
personalized treatment plans Rex MD
makes it easy and it's inexpensive to
get generic and branded Viagra or Cialis
online no waiting rooms no embarrassing
trips to the doctors no insurance and no
co-pays did you know that Viagra can
cost ninety dollars a pill well Rex MD
has generic Viagra for just as low as
two dollars a pill just fill out their
online medical questionnaire a doctor
will review your situation and if
appropriate prescribe you the medication
your medication will ship right to your
door with free two-day shipping it's
fast it's simple it's cheap plus you can
access your loot your U.S license Rex MD
physician anytime you need Rex MD has
already helped over 300 000 guys gain
confidence quickly and conveniently
they're here to help you to take
advantage of their best deal at
rexmd.com Walsh and save up to 90 off by
by paying only two dollars per dosage
that's rexmd.com Walsh for up to 90 off
go to rexmd.com for more details and
safety information
but what did he say there
um well he said nothing at all that was
nothing that was a whole rhetorical
parade of nothing
and this to me is the real tragedy
right like if we if we must have
extremist leftist militants in our
society
I'd prefer for them to at least be
authentic okay if we have to have them
it's not the worst thing to have a
culture you know a culture at war
between two factions who are deeply
opposed to one another it's not the best
thing it's not a good thing you prefer
not to have that situation but it's not
the worst thing I think the worst thing
is this
where we're at War
but we're at war with people who speak
exclusively in cliches
people who are you know
um
absolutely phony who are as human and
authentic as chat Bots
this is a culture War but a very
decadent one
as so many of its participants are play
acting basically
we heard the Chuck Todd clip at the top
of the show
there's someone who doesn't buy this
stuff well you know scientists say that
gender is on a spectrum doesn't buy that
at all it does not even he does he does
not believe any part of that but he's
pretending to
all of these people are pretending
which I think just makes it all the
worst I'll do it for this portion shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]